please be with you welcome to this
week's episode of the DS show we have a
lot to talk about imagine if you now had
never experienced snow a blessing from
God and now it's coming down in an area
also that doesn't get much snow and now
you're admiring it and now you're opened
up to a whole new nightmare now a
bullets raining at you over a dozen and
that's what happened to a Muslim out in
Dallas and we have someone from Dallas
to tell us kind of the details of what
happened because you're not getting much
from the media are you and we're also
going to be talking about the new
atheist in a in that hate speech in the
intolerance towards the most peaceful
people in the world that's right those
who have submitted to the Creator not
the creation those people who love Jesus
they loved his mother too and there's a
rise of hatred towards these people
Islamophobia it's cause we have a lot to
cover on this week's show don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
this is the this is the thing you know
this is the danger this is the huge shot
lake home doctor say how are you a lot
nice to see it nice to have you on a
Dean show you're a doctor by profession
co author author of many books yes I
wouldn't say many books but the main
book we've written in 2004 was called
God Islam and the skeptic mind so you
your pert you're pretty busy out there
doing some great wonderful work tell us
now I had mentioned a story yes about a
tragic event you know something start
off with something beautiful someone
admiring just snow yeah right and then
what happened from there yeah so
honestly just a few days ago some of you
may have seen in the news probably most
of you haven't but I was just planning
for my trip to come to Chicago from
Dallas and I get a bulletin from care
DFW and they say that there was an Iraqi
immigrant who was just out with his wife
you know near the Richardson mosque and
you know Dallas doesn't get a lot of
snow but we recently got four or five
inches including snow at night so it's
very beautiful Subhan Allah you know how
it beautiful it is when the snow comes
down he was outside admiring the snow
taking pictures outside his apartment
complex and lo and behold 15 bullets you
know put him down you know it's
extremely unfortunate but this is the
way things are going in this country
right now and we need to make a
difference right now and we need to
stand up for our rights as you might
predict they're not really giving it a
lot of coverage right now and they're
not really saying anything clear about
his motive but when you shoot a guy 15
times you know who's just taking
pictures of the snow you know it
obviously brings up some major questions
yeah it's very sad
and our condolences to all the family
members and everybody out there and it's
it's a shame that you know you have you
know such fringe elements who represent
I believe the numbers were like point
zero one nine percent and and the news
is constantly bombarding the American
people with certain extreme elements as
if they represent Islam but now you have
something at home here on home base
definitely you had it had this you know
terrorism taking place and and the
American people aren't aware of it
because you think because it's persons a
Muslim allahu ahlam you know Allah knows
best but we wouldn't be surprised I mean
in dallas there is kind of a growing
awareness of this summer some of you may
have heard also just a few weeks ago in
the news about pamela geller you all
have maybe heard of her viewers of heard
of her where she's head of the American
defense foundation she announced a
cartoon contest have you heard about
that no I'm yeah this was big news where
they had some protests in the Dallas
area when the sound vision came to
Dallas to do a fundraising event and a
bunch of them got together and were
protesting the event but a few weeks
after that event and this is literally
just a few weeks ago they announced that
they're going to be having a cartoon
drawing contest about guess who prophet
muhammad's loss of them and they're
accepting submissions from around the
world online and they want cartoons that
will insult the profits loss of them and
they're intentionally doing all this and
of course Pamela Geller announced that
there's a place called a garland special
event center it's a big convention
center in the Dallas suburb they're
announcing that they're going to have
the award ceremony there and they're
awarding $10,000 to the winning entry so
this is the climate we're living in and
this is the you know these are the times
we're in so it you know either we sit
down and take it or we we respond in a
positive way and put our positive
message out the found of founding
fathers of America do you think this was
the intent that was created by the
freedom of speech now was it actually
freedom because it seems like it's more
of a freedom to insult you follow me we
would we take strong
inception to even insulting Jesus peace
be upon him Moses Abraham IT messengers
who call people to p's call them to have
a loving relationship with the crater
that happens in and out to insult them
to insulting Jesus or any we we take
strong exception to obviously we don't
do anything now that would break the law
but what would your comments on this
about the freedom to insult going away
from really the was this the intent of
the founding fathers do you think
absolutely not that's why there are
plenty of laws in the US also that do do
have some limitation on it to a lot of
people don't realize that but there are
laws that limit freedom of speech laws
against libel against slander and so
forth and that's why I say we as Muslims
need to be well aware of our rights and
we the key thing we're asking for we're
not asking for special treatment we want
fair treatment so if we're not going to
be insulting other people if we're not
insulting the president or other
prophets or other people like that then
we shouldn't be either right and that's
not an unfair thing to ask for and here
too we talked about the you know the
American Way of life and the American
dream I mean this person who was just
shot was an Iraqi immigrant right he
came from what environment he came from
an environment where they were shooting
all the time he came to a place where he
thought it would be more peaceful could
start a new life and look what happens
so that's the antithesis of the American
dream unfortunately so it was very
enforcement yeah there's a you know as
you mentioned I mean there's there's
limits to these things and now we have
yet another piece of video from that bus
I want to play this for the first time
now
well if he wasn't identifiable before
the leader of that chant is certainly
identifiable now and as soon as you i
think the the one of the writers at that
magazine some years back he criticized a
certain group of people and they
actually fired him absolutely i did you
hear about that or you know so now yeah
this happened in france 2 i'm sure you
know the charlie hebdo thing was been in
the news but i'm sure you're well aware
that there was a cartoonist in France it
was fired that's you know that's what
I'm talking about exactly yeah and he
had drawn some pictures of Nicolas
Sarkozy's son and making fun of his son
who had married a Jewish woman what
happened fired immediately exactly but
it seems like it's open day yeah on
those who I mean want the I mentioned
the most peaceful people I mean
seriously if you if you look at it you
know historically if you look at it in
context Muslims you know Jews actually
ran towards from persecution towards the
Muslim lands and were taken care of
absolutely there are more Jews alive
after World War Two in Albania than
before World War two there's no evidence
of any Jew being turned over to the
Nazis to save a life is to go to
paradise I would sooner have my son
killed and break my vessel I always ask
these people what was it was it better
was it the Quran what was it that you
risked you your family risked everything
to save Jews in many cases strangers in
it absolutely and that's why ice to keep
emphasizing we've got to get that
positive message out you know in this
book to as part of that God Islam in the
skeptic mind it helps to promote
understanding of the Muslim perspective
because we have a lot to offer right we
have so much to offer when it comes to
these age-old philosophical questions
and with respect to tolerance and
diversity so we need to get that message
out we have a lot to talk about we just
wanted to give kind of a
a picture that people can now really see
what's going on out there and this was
one of those tragic events and then it
didn't it didn't stop there before they
had the chapel hill you had the three
innocent tops the low humidities and
we're going to be talking about also the
New Atheism absolutely yeah it's an
important trend that our viewers really
need to be aware of yeah so we're going
to take a break you're not going
anywhere I'm not going anywhere we're
allowed to talk about with the author of
God Islam and the skeptic mind here in
the Dean show don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below please also
help support the V show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the Dean show so do you feel it i mean
the people in the community i mentioned
that there's a rise in hate speech so
that there is a rise of hatred and
tolerance towards see those people who
worship the Creator another croatian
muslims and if some people link it back
to the time when the holocaust happened
you had these cartoons against the the
minority jews at the time yes and they
were dehumanized and the media everybody
was up against them and you know made
them look as if they were unhuman and
uncivil and then what happened is yes
that great tragedy you see the
similarity with what's going on here
solutely you're absolutely right yes and
that's why i keep saying either we sit
down and take it or you know we do our
job and we do our part because you know
the fact is with with things happening
around the world you know a common
person on the street is just going to
watch TV and and have negative
impressions of us but if we do a better
job of getting our message out we can
slowly start to change the time and
you're doing a great job with this book
tell what what do you mean when you talk
about the New Atheism what is the new
atheist yeah really we were just talking
about that that this is really a trend
that we really need to be aware of there
are a number of authors some of them are
scientists some of them are biologists
some of them are journalists who are
putting out books and being very
aggressive with the media TV programs
and so forth where they're not just
promoting atheism but they're very
aggressively attacking religion God
Islam Christianity everything and
anything related to it and and we really
need to be aware this and I'll give you
one example why the very fact that we
wrote this book years ago was motivated
by one fact and what happened was my
father who is a co-author of this book
say it farid ahmed he used to be a
professor at the islamic university in
malaysia and he used to visit me in
Dallas so there was some older uncles
had some kids who are in their 20s now
and they said can you please come and
talk to my kids and we're like why
what's going on they're not Muslim
anymore so hollow they're in their 20s
they grew up in a Muslim family they're
not even Muslim we go there and we
talked to them and what happens there's
typically their doubts come down to a
lot of the doubts that are addressed in
this book meaning they have doubts about
the existence of God they have questions
about science and evolution and how that
relates to religion they have questions
about evil and suffering they have
questions about freewill predetermine
ism they have questions about ethics and
if it's relative or not does this really
need god yes or no you know questions
abound this society teaches you to
question everything and a lot of us
don't realize that our kids are growing
up in that environment going to
university here going to college here
and when they take these types of
classes they're taught to think a
certain way and a certain questions so
we have to again have a better or do a
better job of providing answers to these
questions now someone comes up to
university students and he starts to say
look I don't believe in God but I
believe in science that's right have you
heard this statement so what do you tell
them so yeah so it's a very common
notion in this book we go over like
eight or nine different points that
actually proves that science is not as
absolute as people perceive it to be and
there's a lot of information about that
so for example just just to give you a
couple right now a lot of the so-called
empiricists or modern scientists want to
limit the scope of science to observe
phenomena when you limit the scope of it
right at the outset as an a priori
condition then how are you going to have
anything relevant about anything
metaphysical the best example of that is
it's analogous to like some fish who are
in the ocean they're talking amongst
themselves and they're like one fish
comes to the other and says you know
there's this other crazy fish who thinks
there's something called mountains and
he's describing this huge thing but
there's there's no way that's total
nonsense right because they're living in
their own world their whole world has
been limited to the ocean so if
scientists limit their
whole scope to what is observed only and
how can you achieve anything meaningful
about that which is metaphysical or what
transcends the physical realm similarly
there are a lot of criticisms of the
scientific method the fact that it's you
know impa bias can come into the
interpretation of results you can have
the same results and have them interpret
it in many different ways science is not
as absolute as people think it is you
know seeing is not always believing
there are things like optical illusions
marriages you know those things are also
there too and another key important
point I'll close on that is that you
know there are certain types of
phenomena that are not necessarily seen
but we know they exist right for example
emotions like love anger jealousy we all
know they exist but we infer their
existence right and that's why at least
some of the scientists who are believers
in God say look there is a role for
using observation obviously you can't
deny that but then you can infer the
existence of other entities based on
that right and that's where science can
play a more meaningful role in
harmonizing this perceived conflict
between science and religion because you
know in Islam we've never had that [ __ ]
we've never had that kind exactly you
know in fact science is all subservient
to God and the rules and laws of the
universe so we've never had this
conflict but in Christianity we've had
this conflict and now in our modern
societies this conflict is just growing
right where there's that perception that
you said do you know anything about the
recent studies about the god spot yes
I've heard that yeah in the brain where
they say yes familiar what do you know
about that yeah so there are there is
some research studies that say that
there may be some so-called in wired or
inherent characteristics of human beings
that seek like a higher power but in
reading again in talking about New
Atheism they immediately dismiss all
that by saying that look there may be
some tendency towards that
but that they'll say that that doesn't
mean it's true and they'll say that it's
or they'll give it an evolutionary or
adoption Ares spin to it where they'll
say this just helps human beings to cope
with the world but they'll say it has no
real truth in it it doesn't prove that
there is a God is just saying that human
beings have evolved this type of
tendency or propensity no disrespect
intended for anybody out there who
practice any any religion but isn't this
a byproduct now because we haven't had
this conflict with science as you
mentioned you know Islam was at the
pinnacle of discoveries and everything
because Islam and create the Quran Allah
the Creator encourages the thing to
ponder you know to do this but now in
Christianity you had conflicting now
science and the war between the Bible
and the contradictions what do you
thought son is yes so that's what I mean
that that conflict goes back several
hundred years it goes back to the time
of the Renaissance or the so-called Age
of Enlightenment and to me that conflict
has certainly not gone away but it
really means that again we as Muslims
where we don't have this conflict we
have to get our message out and let
non-muslims know that there really
shouldn't be this conflict and
everything in the Quran and the hadith
and our traditions are in consonance and
in resonance with science and not the
other way around unfortunately I said
when I talk to people I tell them that
unfortunately the response of the church
and some of the things that are present
in the Bible and in their Christian
traditions do have some conflict with
modern science and it's natural that
that developed it was inevitable but
that's where we have to get our message
out and say look all religions are not
the same you know we say that Islam is
completely in harmony with with with
true science and that's an absolute fact
if you look into this way of life that
is simple it's based on simplicity it
has the evidence the proofs and it's all
there and that's what it distinguishes
it from the rest it's lost amisha to the
crater not the creation and the Quran
temporary tamper proof it's a living
miracle read it check it out we right
back with
more here on the Dean show Islamic
terrorism misconception Muslims are
terrorists this is by far the biggest
misconception of Islam given unfairly by
stereotyping in the public image that
the media gives has anyone else noticed
how when a specific group of people
attack another group of people it is
labeled as a hate crime but when a
Muslim opens fire on anybody it is
quickly regarded as terrorism many
political dictators and officials or
extremist groups use the name of Islam
as a strategy to garner followers and
attention when many of their practices
go against the true basis of Islam the
media has also portrayed Islam as a cult
or a club where if you join you become a
terrorist and that is now part of your
agenda however all over the world people
practice Islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life there are many
verses in the Quran that go against the
idea of terrorism some of these verses
include fight the way of Allah those
that fight you but do not transgress
limits for God does not love
transgressors this basically means do
not fight except in self-defense and
even in doing so do not go beyond
defense another verse states if they
seek peace then you seek peace which
means do not attack people for no reason
or kill innocent people there is nowhere
in Islam whether it be in the Quran or
the teachings of Muhammad that promotes
the killing of innocent people
please subscribe to the dvo follow us on
our official facebook and twitter pages
in the links below please also help
support the V show by making a donation
in the link below back here on the DS
show or dr. Saeed what's the Islamic
view on on the DAR was evolution what do
we believe as Muslims on evolution yeah
that too is a again a very important
topic because it's one of the key tools
that then movement of New Atheism holds
on to it's a key tool that they've used
for years and decades to try to weaken
the foundation of religion and belief in
God in the book we go over again at
least six or seven points in detail that
are very logical criticisms of the
modern movement of evolution you know as
Muslims we have no issue with what we
call microevolution or adoption arey
changes you know for example Darwin
spoke about the finches on the Galapagos
Islands and how their beaks tended to
change slightly based on their
environment no problem with that right I
don't think any Muslim would but when
you extend that and they have and
they've extended that definition of
Darwinian evolution to include the fact
that so-called there's a they say that
all species arose by descent from a
single common ancestor so it's not just
about saying that human beings came from
apes it's saying that apes monkeys
giraffes crocodiles everything a whole
planets all are sorry all creatures came
back to a single origin or a single
ancestor which is a huge statement you
know and that's the one of the big
projects to give you a couple examples
there's something called the missing
fossil record if everything came down to
a single ancestor shouldn't there be you
know millions of intermediary stages of
fossils between creatures right the fact
is they don't have it and even if you
look at some of the top evolutionists
like Richard Dawkins they have no
explanation for that even Darwin himself
said that this could be one of the
biggest criticisms of
of evolution and their answer right now
is just to say well you know where we'll
eventually find those those missing
links we haven't found it right just to
give you another example does Darwinian
evolution explain anything about the
origin of the universe or the origin of
the first cell or the origin of human
beings nothing absolutely nothing so how
does that put down religion no it can't
is it still doesn't explain those right
another quick example does it say
anything about how consciousness evolved
Richard Dawkins again in the book The
God Delusion he says that consciousness
is the most profound mystery facing
biology because you can explain certain
micro evolutionary adaptations but how
do you get this sudden dramatic leap
from a physical body to having
consciousness where we are aware and
we're able to talk about these things
now no explanation they'll try to give
it a material explanation because
they're materialists but they haven't
been able to so for that too they say
well we'll eventually find that
explanation yeah you know there's a lot
a lot of doubt here is certainly not
absolute okay now we have a lot of God
conscious scientists scientists who go
deep into science and they realize that
there's no way mathematically
scientifically that all of this could
come by chance I mean I just can't wrap
my mind around any logical sensible
person now obviously what separates
Islam from the rest is that you know all
these man-made religions where people
are worshipping sticks stones bones
human beings men women stars and all and
the universe but we just were should one
who created all these things and it's
not just makes sense but why do
scientists many of them in the
Universities they get blacklisted now
that's as soon as they start arguing
design why is that do you think that's
right well that's you know look who's in
charge all right so just like everything
else they've been as I said they've been
very aggressive in their movement and
spreading their ideas it's taken hold
you have key people in politics also who
support that ideology and so it starts
to slowly take hold but the fact is
there you're right there are still
people who do
as an example in the book we mentioned
there are actually several hundred
professors academics doctors scientists
who provide biological criticisms or
scientific criticisms of evolution and
that's available and it mentioned in the
book so they're out there but you know
it's still a minority but their
arguments are there and we've got a got
to look into them they're not the ones
that are now on the payroll of the
University and now they're not bound to
maybe losing their job or what yeah so
they can speak freely we you know we
were talking about freedom of speech
earlier some of them do end up losing
their job conveniently or based on some
other you know explanations or
rationales but you're right that's
another way that freedom of the speech
is being suppressed in this country
unfortunate do you sometimes I mean we
use a lot of these because it's innate
in us to believe in the crater now you
have a lot of things out there calling
us to fulfill our cardinal desires and
let's talk about let's say the young
university student now here you know you
know that to be in school to be in the
university is different in to cut class
and be out there just you know doing
whatever you want that's too easy right
but now you have less people in the
higher you go up and Islam the more you
go up the more discipline it takes the
more you control yourself to become a
better human being so do you think some
people use this there are some
legitimate doubts that obviously if you
ask questions and you're sincere God
will guide you but you think some people
use these doubts to go ahead and just
leave off religion all together so they
can go have a good time you get where
I'm customer yeah absolutely and we know
and from Islamic to you know I'm sorry
not to say you can't have a good time in
Islam but just to go do some of the most
wretched things yes absolutely so we
know very well in Islam that Satan makes
sin and disobedience very tempting for
us and very beautiful youyou defies it
and especially when you're at a young
age you know you're you're constantly
weighing those decisions should i do
should i not do self control what they
call mujahidin f's yeah that's self
control that's really the core essence
of islam so it's not easy but the fact
is that God has given a
the ability to reject you know this
insinuations and prodding zuv Satan too
so he knows what we're capable of like
he says in the Quran to that the
Shaitaan doesn't have any soltan or
authority over us say Satan also says in
the Quran philately mooney minus mu and
physical so don't blame me blame
yourselves so what does that mean it
means that in the end you can't just
blame Satan you can't come and blame God
for your own problems you've still got
to go back to your own free will and say
that look I can make the right decisions
and that's where knowledge comes in
that's where our ibadah comes in that's
where our Dean comes in to help make it
easier and that's where you have to have
the right social group the right peer
group to help make those decisions
easier now you have a lot of things you
cover here me some great things what is
evo suffering God in science the
scientific God mathematic proves medical
proves on Darwin evolution list goes on
Islam and knowledge and all of these
things now if somebody really is having
some doubts parents want to help their
kids university student really wants to
okay have these doubts care do you feel
that if they go through this book
sincerely looking for the truth that
this will help to shatter those doubts
we honestly do it's not me thinking that
we've actually because this book came
out the first edition in 2004 and
alhamdulillah it's been very well
received you've had a guest on this show
bread friend of mine oh yes he actually
mentioned his book on the show that's
right and and a lot of the viewers I'm
sure no brother no Mon well he lives in
the Dallas area I know him well
hamdullah he himself when he described
his story when he was in New York tells
about how he had all those all those
doubts right and he was basically
agnostic or atheist he himself says that
right yes but then his whole life was
transformed so that's when he read this
book too he felt that it addressed a lot
of the key questions that people had you
know when they're going through these
difficult times so again we can't be
naive especially if we're kind of older
parents and our kids are younger here
we've emigrated from other countries we
have to realize that our kids are
exposed to a lot in this society
and they're exposed to various questions
and doubts and if we don't answer them
what's going to happen you know a lot of
the social scientists save you don't
take care of these things with each
successive generation what happens you
start to lose your language you lose
your culture and then you lose your
religion yes right unless you really
work hard to take care of these things
absolutely where can people get the book
where can people get the book soham
delights on available on amazon.com or
trying to get some additional Muslim
distributors but alhamdulillah balai kai
said amazon com that's right God Islam
and the skeptic mine doctor say thank
you so much for being with us so much
really appreciate it i thinkin ain't
gonna peace be with you saw me and that
was not saved God Islam the skeptic mind
get the book and hatred hate speech is a
bitter pill to swallow and it only makes
you more sick that's right and Islam
doesn't teach us to be out there hating
teaches us really to love and we love
for all of mankind so we really to
combat this negative force we need to
create awareness we need to spread the
love show the piece of Islam get out
there and invite people share with
people it's not our job to try to
convert anybody know but it's out there
to give people knocked alternative to
all of the social illnesses the diseases
that are clogging the mind people are
are on antidepressants prozac people are
committing suicide and it's loud so
mission to create another creation yes
has all the solutions but if they don't
want to accept they reject hey to you
your way to ours ours but now we might
have a new friend a neighbor that sees
that hey this Muslim really cares about
me and society by how they're going to
know that if they get all the
information from the haters from the
islamophobes who are just making
themselves more sick we hope that you've
gotten a benefit we'll see you next time
inshallah condolences to all those
innocent people who have been recently
killed that you don't get to hear a lot
that a lot of that on the media and stay
safe we'll see you next time subscribe
if you haven't already peace be with you
so no Michael please subscribe to the
Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the link
below please also help support the d
show by making a donation in the link
below